talk about the drill
scene in new york it's um
it's crazy right now and you know i feel
like
obviously chicago started it uk had
their way but new york's got it right
now
um fully um was that always like
the type of like when you because you
know me growing up as a hip-hop head i
think in new york i think a [ __ ]
boom bap lyrical rap [ __ ] or 50 cent g
unit you know what i'm saying
that's more relatable the first one i
really that's me like i i didn't
i was never so in tune with music but it
was always around me
right i never had like a specific person
i listened to on a regular but
you know soccer my people's growing up
uh
konpa that's the [ __ ] i heard and then
on the you know you got the r b
artist right so like me like i said when
it comes to
real music in new york it has hints
of what was in the past but it's a whole
new wave
right you know and it's and it is like i
said me i grab a lot of [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] and put it in my tracks you for
me i grab a lot of who should put in my
tracks just
just you know the idea of it is cool
because you're still paying homage
who would you consider kind of like the
godfather of the drill [ __ ] in new york
i think pop smoke was the biggest but i
think he was the biggest but
i mean i think obviously obviously shout
out to fabi i think five is one of those
guys
i'll say i'll say pop pop he
he put it on the biggest stage 100 to me
it's like
that's what the godfather is you know
i'm gonna use
everybody else here it was underneath
you but you was up there
well i think what he was able to do
unfortunately he didn't get to see the
uh
success of the sonic
chances he took on his new album because
he changed up his you know
he made some records that he made a lot
of i mean there was barely any drill
records on that album
and unfortunately you know he didn't get
to see that it paid off